[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARC CRANDALL: Hi, folks.
Can everybody hear me all right?
All right.
Terrific.
My name's Marc Crandall.
I handle Global
Regulatory Compliance
for Google Cloud,
specifically G Suite.
And I want to talk
to you a little bit
today about data protection
and regulatory compliance when
using G Suite.
A little background--
I've been at Google
a little more than 10 years.
I'm a lawyer by trade,
and helped launch
G Suite as a product 10 or 11--
10 and a half years ago.
And I'm part of an
engineering team focusing
on regulatory compliance.
And let's see what we
can talk about today.
So you don't have to
do this by yourself.
You can partner with
us when it comes
to addressing data protection
and compliance needs when
you move to the cloud.
The cloud could be daunting
for a lot of folks,
but we've been doing
it a really long time
and we want you to
be able to leverage
our experience in helping
address this yourselves.
Maybe just by a show of hands,
how many folks in the audience
focus on regulatory
compliance or data protection?
That's terrific.
How many folks in
the room are lawyers?
Good.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
So we're going to talk about
four different main themes
today.
We're going to talk about
your specific industry
that you're in and how you
could conduct a compliance
assessment of what your
regulatory compliance needs may
be.
Now, you may not be in a
regulated industry at all.
Or you could be working with
European data protection
issues, or a bank, or
working with healthcare.
So the point is helping you
conduct that assessment.
The next thing that
we're going to talk about
are transparency tools--
things that you can focus on
to help conduct an assessment of
Google Cloud Services, G Suite
specifically, so you can conduct
a meaningful risk assessment.
The next thing that
we're going to do
is talk about
contracts to show you
where we are taking these
obligations we talk about,
and putting them in writing.
And then finally, I'm
going to talk about some
of the more common
regulatory frameworks
that we've encountered
over the last decade
in providing G Suite
services to millions
of customers around the world.
So let's first focus on
compliance assessments.
What do you need to
look at when you're
focusing on your business
and the move to the cloud?
Now, I'm not going
to sit here and talk
about every regulatory framework
in every country in the world.
I don't think
anyone can do that.
It would make you crazy
and it would make me crazy.
If you think, there are
190 or so odd countries
with maybe four or five
verticals in each country--
personal data, healthcare,
educational records,
financial services, government.
We're talking about hundreds
of thousands or millions
of combinations.
So you are the experts in what
your own regulatory compliance
requirements are for your field.
You have your own
compliance specialists.
You have your own lawyers.
And if you don't, presumably
you have a general sense
of what you've been addressing
over the last few decades
or years that you've
been working with data.
You know where your
regulatory needs are
and you know what countries
are a priority for you.
However, what we can do as
part of this partnership
is that we can
bring expertise with
regards to how
regulatory environments
would apply to cloud computing.
Because we've seen this a lot
over the last several years.
We also have technical expertise
with regards to the services
we provide and how
they can mesh with what
your own regulatory
compliance needs are.
So there's a partnership.
There's also a shared
responsibility, right?
Because if you're going
to be relying on us,
really trusting
us with your data,
then you want to
make sure that we're
doing exactly what we're
supposed to be doing to help
you meet your needs as well.
That also means providing
transparency into our services,
as well as allowing you--
and this is why transparency
is so important--
to allow you to conduct
a meaningful risk
assessment of our services
so that you can build trust,
and rely on us for your work.
So risk assessment--
these are the things
you should be asking when
you decide to adopt a cloud
provider, including G Suite.
And I'll show you where
you can find access
to this type of information
as you conduct your risk
assessment of G Suite.
So obviously, you want to
assess our security capabilities
and you want to compare them
to what your own security
capabilities are
right now, as well
as what might be
expected of you if you
work in a regulated market.
As much as I'd like you to do
this, simply choosing Google
just because we're
Google is not the reason
to be adopting a cloud provider.
You want to be able to
assess what our security
capabilities really are, and
then make a meaningful risk
assessment.
Then you want to think
about ownership of data.
Now, we take the
position that any data
that you store in G Suite,
that you upload to G Suite,
is your data--
belongs to you, does
not belong to us.
We own the services
and you own the data.
And the next thing you
want to think about
is how is the service
provider using the data.
Now, this might not
be as applicable
if you're not in a
regulated market.
But in many markets, and in
many regulatory frameworks,
the usage of data is restricted.
Right?
So think about a
European personal data--
if you're a company
and you have employees,
how that data would
or would not be used.
If you're dealing with
educational records,
let's say FERPA in the United
States, or student records,
or healthcare information that
might be covered under HIPAA.
You want to think about
data use restrictions.
We'll talk about it more
later, but in G Suite,
there are no ads.
Data is not used for ads.
And we provide commitments in
our data processing amendment
that data will be used
for no other purpose
than to provide you
with the services
and to protect that data.
The other thing that's
important we want to talk about
is data incident notification.
That's been a really big
deal over the last few years.
And people may not
realize it, but there
have been many laws
around the world that
obligate our
customers as well as
providers to notify
users that might
be affected by a data incident.
Now, notice I don't say breach.
Because it could
be a data leakage,
it could be an intrusion.
But in any case, if anything
unfortunate like that happens,
you may have an obligation
to notify your customers
or your employees.
As such, we as
the cloud provider
obligate ourselves to notify
you if something like that
ever happens.
We hope it never would,
but we need to make sure
that that is covered.
Data portability-- providing
commitments from your cloud
provider that you
can take your data
and go home if you want
to switch providers,
or just don't like
their services anymore.
You want to consider that.
The other thing to
consider-- and this,
again, comes to particularly
regulated markets--
is what type of data
you're going to be storing.
For example, you might be
thinking about a government
agency that deals with
all types of information,
and classified information.
We wouldn't
encourage necessarily
to have a customer
storing classified data
in a public cloud
on our systems,
notwithstanding the fact that
we have fantastic security
capabilities.
However, a lot of other data
that they may be addressing--
collaboration data, calendaring,
document sharing, email--
could very well be uploaded
and used in the cloud.
So what I'm saying is you need
to look at the type of data
you're dealing with and
decide what is appropriate
for the cloud, per your
assessment, and what isn't.
And we can provide information,
again, regarding our services.
I should also note that
in many, many situations,
moving your data to
the cloud from on prem
would end up being much,
much more secure than what
you could possibly do.
Right?
You've got to realize that.
So you have to weigh the fact
that the data is likely much
more secure in the cloud
versus the type of data
you would actually be storing.
And then hopefully, if there's
a nexus between the two,
that's what you
deploy in the cloud.
Millions and
millions of customers
have conducted similar
assessments, I would say.
And that's why we have such
a great system right now
within G Suite.
Finally, you want to consider
where is the data stored.
Google is a global
provider of cloud services,
so we have data
centers globally.
You need to know where
that information is.
those data centers are.
So again, you can conduct
meaningful risk assessment.
I'll talk a little bit about
data centers and the risk
assessment that we conduct
when we choose a data center
location.
And then finally, you want
to think about third party
security audits with
regards to whether or not
we're inviting third parties to
review our systems to make sure
we're doing what
we say we're doing.
These are examples of
questions that you should
be asking of a cloud
provider-- questions
that we've been
developing answers
to over the course of many years
since we've been doing this.
The first distinction
I absolutely must make,
and I have to dedicate some
time to it specifically here,
is to distinguish G
Suite and consumer apps.
G Suite and the consumer
app counterparts
look very, very similar.
And in fact, the
similarities is somewhat
of a double edged
sword when it comes
to Google and our customers.
The similarity is
fantastic, because it
makes it a lot easier for
end users, for example--
when I say end users, I
mean your own employees
or students--
end users are familiar
with the consumer services,
it makes the utilization of the
similar services in the work
environment very easy.
If they know how to
use consumer G-Mail,
it's very likely they know
how to use the business
counterpart within G Suite.
The same goes for Docs
in the business sense.
And you get the idea.
However, there is a significant
difference between the two,
as I mentioned earlier.
First of all, data is
not used to create ads
or to display ads.
Right?
We provide commitments
in our data
processing amendment-- data
processing terms that restrict
how we can use your data.
See, that's important
for regulated markets.
The other difference is that
G Suite provides customers,
and specifically
their administrators,
with an administrator console--
a C Panel, a control panel.
And the administrators are
responsible for determining
who in their organization
gets accounts,
whether their passwords
should be reset, password
enforceability, whether or not
their account should be turned
off, what systems or what
applications they're allowed
to use, how much data
they have, whether they're
allowed to share outside
the organization.
Our customers are
responsible for doing this.
They are in control.
All right?
We provide the back end
systems that allow for this,
but they are the administrators.
Compare that to consumer
G-Mail account where there
is no system administrator.
You simply go to Google
and create your own account
and decide what you want
to do with it on your own.
The business environment and
the enterprise environment
is very different.
And then finally, in
the enterprise context--
and I just want to touch on it--
we also provide special
enterprise related
functionality, such as
what's available in Google
Vault, which allows for
special retention with
regards to the
data that your end
users may store in the system.
But again, I need to make
the distinction-- in G Suite,
we will not serve
ads and data won't
be used for any other
purpose than to provide
the services as outlined in
our data processing terms.
And I'll talk about
that a little bit later.
So that's the compliance
assessment-- the questions
you want to ask,
the things you want
to consider as you
adopt a cloud provider.
However, everything
I could be saying
to you about what
our capabilities are
could be wrong.
I could be standing
here just lying to you
about what our capabilities are.
What everyone has been
telling you all week,
they could all be lies
and lies and lies.
So how do you know
that they're not lies?
You have to be able to verify
what we're saying is true,
at least from a regulatory
compliance perspective.
I've worked with
regulators for a long time,
specifically about cloud.
And they're certainly adopting
the idea of cloud computing.
Many regulatory
authorities have actually
issued guidance with
respect to cloud.
But they still expect customers
to conduct a meaningful risk
assessment.
And you can't conduct
a risk assessment
unless there's some sort of
transparency into what we're
doing.
And that's where third party
certifications and audits
come in.
It's very important for this.
This is not something
we did when we first
launched, back in the day,
G-Mail for your domain,
or Google Apps, as we used
to previously call G Suite.
But we realized as larger
and larger customers adopted
our services,
adopted G Suite, they
wanted to know whether
we were actually
doing what we say we're doing.
And how do we do that
with millions and millions
of customers?
Well, we didn't have
to invent this process.
There are third party
auditors that we
can invite into our systems,
into our data centers,
to review our processes
and analyze what we're
doing specifically, and
verify what we're doing
is actually what
we say we're doing.
So up here, you see a lot of
pretty little badges and logos.
I'll give you a little
summary of what they mean.
The first thing that's very
important in conducting a risk
assessment is an analysis
of the SOC2 report
that an auditor might provide.
Now, basically what we do when
it comes to a SOC examination--
and I'm going to cover
this very high level,
because that's the
best I can do--
is we invite third
party auditors
to review our processes, our
systems, our data centers,
and to verify that the
controls that we implement
are actually being followed.
And the output of their
analysis is a very detailed,
what we call a
SOC2 audit report.
Several hundred pages--
200 or 300 pages long--
that give you a
detailed description
of what's happening.
We also offer a SOC3, which
is also a synopsis, basically,
of that review.
The SOC2 report is highly
confidential, very detailed,
but quite useful when it
comes to conducting a risk
assessment.
So what you want
to do is you want
to look at that detailed SOC2
audit report, or even the SOC3,
which is publicly available,
and then compare that
to what your own
security capabilities are
or security requirements.
And then you conduct an analysis
or a comparison between the two
to ensure that there
aren't any gaps
that you might need to address.
The other thing that you
want to think about--
so that's a SOC2.
Right?
It's a review of
controls that we've
implemented by a
third party auditor
to verify that what
we're saying is true.
Now we have something which
is slightly different--
ISO.
International Organization
for Standardization--
ISO.
ISO 27001 17 and 18.
This is where we
have third party
auditors come in and audit us
against a specific standard.
ISO, as many of you might
know, is a global organization
that sets standards.
They'll set a security standard.
They'll set a data
protection standard.
They set standards in
all sorts of industries.
But the thing that's
become very important to us
as a provider of cloud services
are their security standards.
So what we've done is we've--
and this was a few years later,
after we started doing SOC
related reports and SAS 70
reports prior to that-- is we'd
invite auditors in to assess us
against this standard.
ISO says that if you want
to comply with 27001,
you have to do these things.
And if you do these
things, and if they
are verified by an
auditor, then you
get a certification,
a diploma basically.
So for several years now, we've
been audited against ISO 27001.
And if you're curious about
what those controls are
that were audited
against, you can actually
contact ISO and order
a copy of the standard
so you can see what
we're complying with.
More recently--
and as I mentioned,
ISO 27001 is a
security standard.
More recently, ISO
has issued 27017,
which are controls that are
specific to Cloud security.
Cloud security.
And naturally, we've
adopted ISO 27017
and have been audited
against that as well.
And then ISO 27018 is
a separate standard
that is geared towards data
protection and privacy.
It's a privacy
standard for the cloud.
So we've also adopted this,
reviewed the controls,
and had auditors examine us
with respect to the requirements
of ISO 27018.
Then also at the
bottom, these are
industry and region specific
certifications or frameworks.
We're also FedRAMP
certified, which
is a US government
certification that
allows us to provide services
to certain government agencies.
We also accept HIPAA data, which
is United States healthcare
information, protected
health information.
And then we also participate
in Privacy Shield
and model clauses.
I'll get to that in
a couple of slides.
The point of this is, though,
we undergo these third party
audits for a reason.
It's very expensive and
it takes a long time.
It's so that you have a means
of verifying what we're saying,
and verifying that what we say
we do is actually what we do.
Just to give you a sense
of-- and this is really just
a high level summary-- of the
type of objectives and controls
that would be reviewed
when we subject ourselves
to an ISO type audit.
Obviously, we talk about
information security
and privacy
compliance, but it also
talks about things
like human resources
or the scope of the standard,
what we do with respect
to incident management.
Remember when I talked
about if there's-- hopefully
there's never going
to be the case--
but if there's a data incident,
being able to provide you
information about it
and in a timely manner.
That's part of one
of these standards.
Cryptography-- whether
or not we're encrypting
the data and in what manner.
The scope of processing.
You remember, I mentioned
that we obligate ourselves
to limit how data is processed
pursuant to our enterprise data
processing amendment?
That's part of the
standard as well.
So if someone asks
you, well, how
do you know Google isn't using
data for advertising purposes,
we can point to the ISO audits.
And in this case, I
think it's ISO 27018.
This gives you a general sense.
But again, as part of
your risk assessment,
if you really want to
conduct your due diligence,
then obtain a copy of
these controls from ISO--
ISO 27001 security, ISO
27017 cloud security,
and ISO 27018 cloud privacy--
and review the controls.
Then you'll get a sense of
what we actually audit against
and what our capabilities are.
This, along with the
SOC2 report I mentioned--
that very detailed 200
to 300 page summary--
or the SOC3, which is
publicly available ,
will give you a sense of
what our overall security
capabilities are as well as
data protection capabilities,
and then compare it to
what your own needs are.
There are also lots of
other online resources.
We have FAQs.
We have white papers.
We have documents that
describe our processes
outside of these audit reports.
You should take a look at them.
You should avail yourselves
of these resources.
We create these for people that
are in regulated industries.
But it doesn't hurt,
even if you don't
think you're dealing with
regulated information-- you're
not a bank, you're not dealing
with European personal data,
or student records, or
educational records.
That's OK.
You can take a look at
these and get a sense
of what we're actually doing.
It gives information
about how we encrypt
the data, general overviews
about security and compliance,
our data centers, we
have security frequently
asked questions.
So the next thing I want to
talk about are data centers.
As I mentioned, we have--
and this is publicly
available, by the way.
If you do a search for
Google data center,
you'll be able to
find this page.
But this is a general
overview of where
we have production data centers
that Google owns and operates
that we use for systems
that would involve G Suite.
And I want to talk
to you a little bit
about why we have chosen
these particular data centers
and why these locations
are important to us.
So first of all, there are
considerations that you might
not be surprised to learn.
For example, bandwidth is
obviously a big issue for us.
We want to make sure that
the data centers enjoy
fast internet
connectivity, which
results in extremely low latency
at reasonable prices to us.
And we also want to
make sure that there
are multiple and diverse
fiber paths to the data center
where we might choose
to have it built.
And notice, we have
distributed data centers
based on that criteria.
Cost-- as I alluded to a
little bit earlier-- cost
is also very important.
We want to make sure
that the location would
allow for energy efficiency
and provide, if possible,
renewable energy options.
These are all engineering
driven considerations.
But from a compliance
perspective,
it goes a little bit
further than that.
Right?
We also want to
consider policy issues.
For example, we don't want
to build a data center
in a place that does not have
political stability, that
does not have a rule of law.
We don't want to see a
data center nationalized,
for example.
We want to make sure that
the countries we might choose
has a good human rights record,
or is a proponent of democracy,
does not censor
political considerations.
All right.
We have to be able to defend
our rights and the rights
of our users when we build
a data center in a country.
And that's why rule
of law is critical.
So for example, where we
build a data center might also
determine, for example,
whether we have the ability
to protect ourselves
and our users in courts
by the mere fact we have
a data center there.
It goes beyond that, also.
We want to make sure
that content is not
going to be a problem.
The country that we
build a data center in
should allow us to be
able to protect ourselves
against copyright infringement
claims or defamation
or trademark.
Right?
So we have to consider
any exposure there.
And finally, you won't see
data centers in any countries
where we, as a cloud provider,
aren't allowed to do business
with people in that country.
Right?
There are countries
that we are prohibited
from even considering or
doing business in that might
be on the OFAC restricted list.
These are the considerations.
And again, you should know
where the data is stored as part
of your risk assessment.
And I should also let you
know that since we do utilize
a global distributed
network system,
you should also consider
that when you determine
the type of data you store.
All right.
But you should also remember
that it's quite possible
that when you think there are
restrictions to, for example,
things that might relate
to data sovereignty,
they might not
actually be the case.
For example, when it comes
to European personal data,
we actually provide
and undertake
to utilize frameworks that allow
the export of personal data
from Europe.
A lot of people don't know
that, but it can be done,
and it's done quite readily.
I'll talk a little bit
more about that as well.
So we talked about
transparency, right?
Third party audit reports--
SOC2, ISO certifications,
white papers,
publicly available
information, FAQs.
That's how you can do
your due diligence.
But how do you know that
as soon as you sign up,
we don't do any of it?
Right?
Well, we changed our minds.
We don't want to do third
party audits, right?
Too much trouble.
Too expensive.
You have to have it in writing.
That's where the
contracts come in.
And this is where I can show
you where we put it in writing
and where you can find it.
So we basically offer
three different means
by which we provide
these obligations to you.
First of all, there is, of
course, the customer agreement.
This is what you would click
through when you sign up
for G Suite for business
or for education,
or our other
versions of G Suite.
It provides your
commercial terms--
how much you're going
to pay and for what,
billing and payments
information,
things like technical
support, SLAs.
It also talks about your
data remains yours--
intellectual property.
Remember I mentioned that as
one of the risks assessment
questions?
Who owns the data when you
upload it into a cloud provider
systems?
You do.
That's where we talk about it.
But my favorite part, which
I talk about with respect
to data protection and
regulatory compliance,
are the data processing terms.
We actually have an amendment
that anyone that uses G Suite
can opt into through
the Admin console--
remember, I mentioned
the admin council--
that provides for the data
protection obligations
that we impose on ourselves
as your cloud provider.
We talk about
privacy compliance.
We talk about the
restriction on data use.
We maintain the obligation--
or rather we impose the
obligation on ourselves
to maintain these
third party audits,
which have to be
done periodically.
We talk about things
like data deletion--
making sure that when you delete
a file, it's actually deleted.
Again, we think
about these things
because it comes
up over the years.
You can leverage our
familiarity with this process
in regulatory environment.
And then, of course, not
everyone in the world
is the same.
We leverage global standards for
our third party audit reports,
because we want it to
be able to encompass
as many customers as possible.
So we don't block off or fail
to serve a certain segment
of the market.
But we also provide region
or industry specific
terms based on the size of the
market and how much of a need.
And I'll talk about model
clauses a little bit later,
but that's something specific
to European privacy compliance.
What allows the export
of personal data
to a global network
of data centers?
We provide business
associates agreements,
which is contractual
assurances to our users,
or to our customers, that need
to process HIPAA information--
PHI, patient information
that is protected.
We also provide FSI,
financial services industry--
special audit language that some
Googlers share in the room that
have worked very hard
to help us create,
which will address the specific
regulatory requirements
of our customers in the
financial services industry.
And then finally,
as I mentioned,
we provide clauses related
to our FedRAMP certification,
which is the US
certification that
allow certain government
agencies to use us
for moderate level data.
So this is generally
the construct.
We have the base
customer agreement,
then you have specific
data processing terms,
and then you have region
or industry specific
terms that might be available
for you, depending on where
you're coming to us from.
Let's drill down into the
data processing terms.
So the data processing
terms are, in addition
to our products'
function, is really
what makes the enterprise
service stand out
from the consumer service.
The consumer service, the
consumer privacy policy.
This is where you have
the business oriented data
protection obligations.
It's essentially
like the privacy
policy for the enterprise
service that we're providing.
As I mentioned, it's available
via the admin console.
And it was created with
feedback over the years
from customers and
regulatory authorities alike.
We work with everybody
to get feedback
on this globally available
data processing amendment,
we call it.
It's available to
anyone in the world.
And all you need
to do is opt in.
And very important.
But let's talk a little
bit about, again,
what some of the
obligations are.
And you'll see
some of these pair
directly to what
I was mentioning
as part of the initial risk
assessment of a cloud provider,
as well as things we talked
about with relation to audits.
We include a limitation
on processing.
We include a restriction
on using the data for ads
or for serving ads.
We obligate ourselves to
actually delete the data
when you delete it.
In other words, if
you take an email
and you delete it
from the inbox,
and then you empty your trash,
we provide an obligation
that we will wipe the data
within a certain period
of time.
And similar to the
ISO certifications,
and the number of security
engineers we have,
and our security
capabilities, this
is likely a significant step
up from what people do on prem.
I don't know a lot of people
that actually wipe data
from their servers every time
a piece of data is deleted.
You may do it, but I'll
bet that many folks don't.
We maintain an obligation,
as I mentioned earlier,
to have these third party
auditors come in regularly
and create these audit reports
so you can review them.
In addition to making sure we
maintain these audit reports
throughout the contract,
throughout the term
of the contract, we
make sure we maintain
our certifications-- the ISO
certifications, for example.
We also tell you-- and this is
something we've done with close
consultation with the
regulatory authorities,
particularly in Europe--
is we provide information to
you about our subprocessors.
So what are subprocessors?
These are third parties,
non-Google Inc. entities
that we would use
to process the data.
So for example, Google has
engineers all over the place.
And we have data centers.
So this basically is
information to you
about our own subsidiaries
that process data for you.
Google companies
themselves that would
be involved with processing.
We also have information
about the number
of vendors we use that
would process data as well.
Now, as you can
imagine, as Google,
we don't use many vendors
for processing data.
I think, right now, the
last time I checked,
we had less than 10.
But still, it's good
to know who they are.
And we make it
available to you as part
of your risk assessment.
We also provide an obligation
to notify you, for example,
with regards to these vendors if
the vendor is going to change,
so you know ahead of time.
Just in case if it's
of interest to you.
Again, transparency--
an obligation
to provide you with
information so you can conduct
a meaningful risk assessment.
By the way, I should tell you
that a lot of these obligations
come out of Europe.
For our data
protection framework,
data processing amendment,
data processing terms,
and as you'll learn
later, a lot of our work
is based on the European model.
Because from a data protection
and personal data standpoint,
they offer some of the most
stringent data protection
requirements in the world.
So we hope that if we
achieve this standard,
it will be useful to the rest of
the world to a certain degree.
Now, of course, everyone
has their own requirements.
Every country has their own
requests, their own needs.
But by using a high
standard like Europe
for data protection, as
well as using globally
accepted third party auditing
mechanisms and certifications,
we can create a
framework that is
applicable to as many customers
worldwide as possible.
So we also talk about
our security measures.
We give you an overview of
the security capabilities.
We provide an
obligation to notify you
in the event of a data incident.
All right.
Remember?
I keep talking about that.
This is where we promise
to do in writing.
And then finally, if there
are further questions
that you need
further information,
we provide a link to be able
to contact the data privacy
officer to be able to
get more information.
So that's contracts.
I didn't make it too long.
I didn't want to
make anybody crazy.
Besides, there are hardly any
lawyers in the room, or no one
that will admit it, anyway.
Regulatory frameworks.
Let's talk about that.
So I mentioned that
we try to provide
a service that is useful
to as many customers
worldwide as possible.
But I've also said that we
have a lot of experience
with dealing with regulatory
authorities in markets
that we've served
over the world.
I want to talk to you a little
about some of these markets
and how we have
addressed them directly,
and also what we've seen
from a trend's perspective.
So naturally, the first thing
I'm going to talk about is EU.
You've heard me mention that EU
data protection frameworks are
particularly stringent,
and it's something
that we work very hard
to address always.
And we intend to do so.
So let's talk a little bit
about EU privacy compliance.
And I'm going to start
this story with the EU Data
Protection Directive of 1995.
This was a very important piece
of legislation that basically
directed all the
member states of Europe
to pass their own privacy laws
that mirrored this directive.
That's what's
called a directive,
it directs the member
states to do that.
One of the most important
aspects of the Data Protection
Directive, besides
the protection
of personal data, data
controller, data processor
relationship, the
obligations of the parties--
I'm not going to get into
too much detail on that.
But the prohibition on exporting
personal data from Europe
to any country that did not
maintain adequate privacy
protections as
determined by Europe.
Well, when the Data
Protection Directive
was being drafted
prior to 1995, this
was also prior to when
the internet was being
used for commerce generally.
And that's totally different.
Huge shift.
Now you've got personal
data flying everywhere--
email address, a name,
a picture, e-mailing
from one person to another.
It made the aspect of locating
personal data in a region where
it could be enforced
particularly difficult. Well,
the first thing that happened
with relation to that--
and I'm going to talk about this
from the cloud perspective--
is that the European Commission
created the US/EU Safe Harbor
Framework.
Who here has heard
of Safe Harbor?
Wow.
See, a lot has happened
in the news with regard
to Safe Harbor.
Safe Harbor was a special
framework that was created
between the United States
Department of Commerce
and the European Commission
that would allow the flow
of personal data from Europe
to the United States--
to companies in the United
States, I should say--
that opt to participate in
the Safe Harbor Program.
And thousands and
thousands of companies
signed up to do this,
including Google.
We imported data pursuant to
the Safe Harbor Framework.
But that covered the United
States for cloud providers.
In 2010, the European
Commission created a framework
that would allow the
export of personal data
to anywhere in the world.
And that was a mechanism they
called model Contract clauses.
I won't go into too much
detail, but basically it
was foreign language
that they created
where if this language
exists in the contract
between the customer and, in
our case, the cloud provider,
then data could flow
anywhere in the world
pursuant to the requirements
in the model clauses.
Now, it's not just a question
of a cloud provider copying
and pasting this language,
this boilerplate language
into a contract.
The obligations in
the model clauses
are significant and serious
and expensive and difficult
for us to do.
But we did it, and we do it.
And we began offering
model clauses
somewhere around
December of 2012.
So we offered
customers Safe Harbor,
which was built into
all of our services,
and frankly, used
all across Google.
And then for G Suite, we offered
model clauses as another way
to export personal
data from Europe.
Sort of a parallel
framework, both.
And we started
doing that in 2012.
And then what happened most
recently with Safe Harbor?
Gone.
It was ruled invalid by
Europe's highest court.
Now, in our case,
of course, we never
could have anticipated
that that would
have happened with Safe Harbor.
But we did, thankfully,
offer this parallel framework
for model clauses for several
years before this happened.
So our customers had an
alternative framework
to do this for this data export.
This is important,
even if you are not
based in Europe, by the way.
If you are a multinational
company or organization that
has end users in Europe or users
that are European citizens,
this is also important.
And then of course, the
Department of Commerce
and the European Commission
created Privacy Shield
as a replacement
for Safe Harbor.
So we also offer
Privacy Shield as well.
So we have model clauses
and we have Privacy Shield.
This is, again, for the export
of personal data from Europe.
Important for a
multinational data
center or a cloud provider
that uses international data
centers.
We also have a
contractual obligation--
which I didn't include in the
data processing terms slide,
but I should talk about it--
where we promise to maintain
an alternative framework
to stay a step ahead as
the law changes with regard
to export of personal data.
Now, with respect
to model clauses,
I should note that when
Safe Harbor was invalidated,
pretty much all we were
left with for G Suite was
model clauses as a mechanism
to export personal data
and we had millions and
millions of customers in Europe
or those that had
users in Europe
that we needed to protect
So being that we have
model clauses specifically,
we needed to make sure that data
protection regulators actually
agreed that our use
of them addressed
European requirements for
the export of personal data.
So along those
lines, we submitted
our contracts, our contractual
agreement, the data processing
amendment I mentioned, as
well as our own model clauses
for review by data
protection regulators
in Europe pursuant
to a framework that
was created by the
Article 29 Working Party.
Now, the Article
29 Working Party
is basically the group of
all European data protection
regulators.
They created a process by
which a provider's terms could
be reviewed and the model
clauses could be assessed
as to whether or
not they achieve
European requirements for
the export of personal data.
And happy to say that after a
year of hard work, discussions
with the data protection
regulators, review
of our contracts,
changes as necessary,
we obtained approval from the
data protection regulators that
reviewed our model clauses.
And again, we do
this because it's
very important for
all of our users
who maintain
businesses in Europe
or have end users in Europe.
So basically what this means
is that model clauses--
our customers that are in Europe
that use model clauses don't
need to get special permission
from their data protection
regulator to export
personal data.
And for other countries, it
makes the process much easier.
This makes it much
easier for our customers
to conduct a risk assessment.
If we have any German
privacy lawyers in here,
they would know
exactly what we mean.
And as I mentioned,
it was conducted
pursuant to Article
29 Working Party
guidance, the group
of all European data
protection regulators.
As part of this process, the
lead data protection regulator
who conducted this assessment
was the Irish DPA--
Ireland.
And as part of
this process, there
are two co-reviewers,
two other data protection
regulators that review
this on behalf of Europe.
And the co-reviewers were
the Spanish Data Protection
Authority, who also provided
a lot of great feedback,
and also the Hamburg, Germany
data protection regulator.
And for people that operate
in data protection space,
to have a regulator
based in Germany
sign off on model clauses,
that's a big deal.
And we're very, very
happy to be providing this
to our customers.
So we can't talk about
Europe without discussing
the General Data Protection
Regulation, the GDPR.
Who here has heard of the GDPR?
That's great.
I'm glad to hear that.
And as I tell my colleagues--
the engineering and product
management colleagues--
GDPR does not mean groovy
disco party revolution.
I try to explain this to them.
So do you remember in that slide
where I started with the Data
Protection Directive
in 1995, and how
that was created prior to
the internet being used
for commerce really
and how that created
a lot of interesting
situations for companies
that export personal data
regularly using the internet,
for example.
So Europe decided to update the
EU Data Protection Directive
and create a new version
with a lot of changes
and a lot of improvements, which
will take effect in May 2018.
And notice, I just
should point out,
that this is going to be called
the General Data Protection
Regulation, and not a directive.
They didn't just do
this to confuse us.
The idea is that the
problem with the directive
was that remember I
mentioned each country passed
their own version?
Each version in each country
was slightly different
and made customers
and us kind of crazy.
Cloud providers were getting
a little loopy with it.
Customers didn't know
how to interpret it.
So to try to create consistency
across all of Europe,
or the EU, I should say, they
made this a regulation so
that it has direct force of law.
Now, what's nice about this from
a cloud provider perspective is
that a lot of the things
that we've already been doing
for several years pursuant to
EU guidance from the Article 29
Working Party, like what cloud
providers should be doing--
they have Working Party
opinions with regards to that--
data protection,
obligations that
were in the model
clauses I mentioned.
A lot of those are going to
now be included in the Data
Protection Regulation.
So from a data
protection perspective,
it's very helpful
for us as a provider.
It also maintains similar
data transfer mechanisms
that I talked about.
Remember I mentioned model
clauses and Privacy Shield?
Those types of data
export mechanisms
are going to be consistent and
be maintained within the GDPR.
They may be tweaked.
They may be updated.
But the core concept
still remains.
However, there are
things that are new.
From a data protection
perspective previously
and the way it is today,
customers in Europe,
they are the ones that are
responsible for compliance
with the data protection
requirements in each
of their countries.
They are the ones who are
beholden to their regulators.
Now, we provide all of
these European centric data
protection commitments
to our customers
because they need it,
as customers in Europe
or customers with
European end users,
and also because
it's important for us
as a business to
make sure they have
what they need to be protected
and to use our systems.
With the General Data
Protection Regulation,
the GDPR, now the
providers are also
going to be directly responsible
for the data protection
regulators in Europe.
So not only are customers, but
the cloud providers as well.
That gets our attention.
The other thing is that there
is a very strict timeline when
it comes to data incident
or breach notification.
That's a really big deal.
Now, as I mentioned
for years, we've
been providing data breach
obligations or data incident
notification obligations.
But now, they've got a real,
very challenging timeline,
which has gotten the attention
of the entire industry
as well as customer base.
Also, fines--
fines are extremely
high now for noncompliance.
So that also gets the
attention of the consumers
and the providers as well.
And there's also an express
requirement for data
portability, which didn't
exist in prior guidance.
Remember we talked
about the obligation
to be able to allow
you to take your data
and go home, move to
a different provider?
That's now actually
in the regulation.
So from a compliance
perspective,
we're in pretty good shape.
But we are definitely
focusing on the regulation,
which is going to be
taking effect next year.
And stay tuned for
more information.
We're absolutely going to
be updating you with this.
Now, as I mentioned,
this section
talks about the regulatory
frameworks we see most often.
And I can't talk about the
millions of combinations
in every country.
But I can talk about
general key themes as well.
So as I've mentioned
the risk assessment--
how important that
is and the ability
to look at provider's
terms and audit reports
and certifications.
If I want to talk about a
common theme across industries
and across regulators and
across countries, that's it.
Conducting a meaningful
risk assessment.
Don't just use Google
because we're Google.
Right?
I've actually seen
someone get in trouble
with a regulatory
authority because they
didn't do a risk assessment.
Now, again, this doesn't
mean that everyone
is beholden to a
regulator or anyone
deals with regulated data.
But if you do, just
do your homework.
So that way, one
day, if you ever
do have to talk
to your regulator,
you can say, yes, I
did my due diligence.
Here, these are the
reports that I reviewed.
Here is a summary.
Here are the certifications
that they have.
Here are white papers.
Here is our customer agreement
where obligations are outlined.
That's really a
common theme I see.
And you also want to,
as I mentioned before--
and again, it's
important to stress--
you want to think about the
type of data you're storing.
Most of our customers,
our millions of customers,
can store all of their data.
But there might be some that
are dealing with classified
information, or certain corpuses
of data that might otherwise be
restricted .
Regulatory authorities also
like to maintain oversight.
So if you're a bank and you're
regulated by your banking
regulator, they have to have
the ability to audit you.
Years ago, when I was practicing
law in the regulated market
space, I was a
financial regulator.
And we had to have the
right as regulators
to audit our customers' records.
So if you're a bank-- and we
have banks that are customers--
and you move to
the cloud, you have
to think about how you're
going to maintain that access
for your regulators.
Are you going to grant them
an administrator account
so they can access the data?
What's going to be the
process for doing this?
Just think about it.
The regulatory
authorities also expect
that regulated
industries, like banks,
have to be able to
audit us directly.
Audit us directly, not just
look at our audit reports.
All right.
And the other thing
to think about
is that many regulatory
authorities already have
guidance on adopting cloud.
So don't think that you
have to do this from scratch
or you have to rely just on
everything I'm telling you.
It's very possible that they
may already have guidance.
I know lots of countries that
already have guidance with
regards to cloud adoption.
So from a financial
services perspective,
and from an FSI perspective,
as I had mentioned,
we've worked very hard to
create special terms for banks,
for example, that give
them these types of rights.
It gives the customer the
right to audit us directly.
It even gives their regulators
the right to audit us directly.
We'd prefer them to use the
third party audit reports,
but it is there if they need it.
They could even verify
the physical controls
of our data center.
We don't like to open up
our data center floor.
It's very private.
And again, it's
a security issue.
But if there must be an
audit or a verification,
we can make that happen as
well for certain customers
of a certain size, for example,
in the financial services
industry.
So these are the trends,
for example, in FSI.
But let's talk
about other areas.
You heard me talk about the
Health Insurance Portability
and Accountability Act--
HIPAA.
And just remember that that
involves whether or not
you can store protected health
information, PHI, in the cloud.
And I'm happy to say that
after many years of saying no--
my saying no-- we
can now say yes, you
can store PHI in the cloud.
It's something that we've
worked very hard for because
of customer demand, market
demand in the United States.
I should mention, by the way,
that this is a US framework.
HIPAA does not apply
to other countries.
But it's very important for
customers that deal with PHI.
Think about a university
that wants to adopt G Suite
and they have a
research hospital.
And remember I told you to think
about the types of data that
would be stored in the cloud?
Before we agreed to
store HIPAA data,
universities could
use us for all
of their staff, all
of their students,
all of their professors,
except they couldn't store PHI.
Now they can, because we will
sign a business associates
agreement.
We've also provided
our customers
with a HIPAA
implementation guide,
basically an instruction manual
on how to use G Suite if you're
going to store PHI data.
Speaking of G Suite
for education,
we also take into
consideration FERPA--
the US Family Educational
Rights and Privacy Act.
I'm glad it's written
up there for me.
This involves the
protection and restrictions
on how you could
process or store
student records or student
directory information.
That's also something we
take into consideration
to help our customers that
would like to adopt G Suite.
Again, these won't be applicable
to everyone in the room,
but just to show that
we are paying attention
to this for customers.
And then finally, with
the US government,
you heard me talk about FedRAMP.
We have an authorization to
operate, an ATO, at the FIPS
199 Moderate Impact Level.
So this allows
government agencies
to utilize our services pursuant
to this FedRAMP certification.
And then as long as we're
talking about governments,
the United Kingdom--
we subscribe to the NCSC,
National Cybersecurity Center
cloud security
principles, which allows
for government adoption in
certain markets within Europe.
And we're also featured on the
government G-Cloud marketplace
through our partners.
So as I mentioned, we try to
provide as broad a framework
as possible to apply to as
many customers as possible.
And within select
markets, we can also
provide more, such as Europe,
healthcare, education,
and government.
And we're working on more and
more of these frameworks for G
Suite as well as in Google
Cloud Platform, which
you heard about in other
parts of this week's sessions.
And yes, we do have
a number of banks
that have adopted our services.
And we've also
worked directly with
many regulatory authorities
throughout the world.
As a matter of fact,
the Dutch National Bank,
which is up there in
blue, they actually
provided us with
direct authorization
to provide services to banks.
So they've already authorized
G Suite as a provider
to banks in that country based
on the extensive engagement
that we've undertaken
with the DNB.
Now, not all regulators do that.
They don't verify
specific vendors.
Other regulators will
issue cloud guidance
that you might see in other
countries like in the UK
or in Australia.
But in many other cases,
we'll work directly
with the regulatory authorities
to provide information
about our services,
get their feedback.
The other thing we
do is, in many cases,
remember I mentioned
that sometimes regulators
will issue cloud guidance?
Right?
So in many cases, thankfully,
the regulators actually
talk to the providers so
they know a little bit
about what they're writing.
So in many cases,
we'll provide guidance
to regulatory authorities.
And in some cases, we'll
work with regulators
directly along
with our customers,
depending on the
country or the market.
So this is just a
small example of some
of the regulators that I
have worked with directly
or my peers, as well
as our customers.
So let's see, what have
we talked about today?
We've talked about
the importance
of conducting an assessment
of your cloud provider
and of G Suite.
You may not be in
a regulated market.
You may not be dealing
with regulated data.
But you should think about it
and conduct that assessment
if you are, specifically.
We talked about the transparency
resources we provide.
Third party audit reports,
certifications, ISO,
white papers, frequently
asked questions document,
online resources, to
make sure that we're
doing what we say we're doing.
And then making sure that
we put it in writing--
where to find these terms.
And by the way, if you want to
see the G Suite data processing
amendment, just do a search
for G Suite data processing
amendment.
You'll find it.
And then finally, I
gave you an example
of some of the most common
regulatory frameworks
that we've been addressing
over the last few years
based on our experience in
providing this to business.
But ultimately, the
takeaway is that we'd
like you to consider partnering
with Google for data protection
and compliance.
You know your industry.
We know the cloud.
And together, we
can really do a lot.
If you would like more
information generally,
please find us on the web--
google.com/gsuite.
And I'd like to thank you
for listening, and can also
take questions for a few
minutes, if anyone has them.
Thank you very much, folks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]